all right welcome to my round eight
recap from Vegas
this was a long game and the ninth and
Final Round starts in uh I think less
than an hour so not gonna have too much
time to go in depth but I do want to
share uh this game because it's super
interesting it was a really uh
hard-fought battle and I was playing
against Alexander kratchatov who is a
feeding master and I've never played
them before but up until this round he's
been having a good tournament so I knew
it would be a tough game and I did a
little bit of prep and he went into the
line I was expecting which was a Queen's
Gambit declined exchange variation after
cd5 eb5 I checked his chess.com games
and he's played this numerous times now
the thing that surprised me about his
opening play was after what was kind of
a a basic line he he started taking a
lot of time
and uh we can see maybe starting around
here
um he played his first several moves
very quickly uh but then with Knight E2
he took five minutes and after rookie
eight Queen C2 A5 Bishop G3 took another
eight minutes and the reason why I was
surprised was this was probably the most
predictable line I could have played in
it like if you look at my games in the
database and my online games uh I play
this line a lot with uh with Bishop D6
and this A5 move
um so I have a feeling he didn't do too
much specific prep like maybe he just
saw I play Queen's got declined and he
thought he would just stick with his own
repertoire
um but this is kind of an offbeat and
tricky line that if White's not prepared
then it can be sometimes difficult to
figure out the nuances over the board
now Bishop G3 is not the most common
move
um now I will note here there's a trap
if like castles this is a blunder due to
Bishop takes H2 and I've had many games
online including in title Tuesday where
players walk into this and then G5 is
winning for black
so the main moves rather than castling
are usually H3 or sometimes A3 because
my plan is to play Knight A6 and Knight
B4
but after Bishop G3
um I did check this line uh right before
the game this morning and I took and
this is a move I've actually never
played before I've had this position a
handful of times online and I've usually
played Knights A6 but the reason why I
took was I've actually been working a
lot on developing my preparation for
this line because I'm working on a
course against one D4 which hopefully
will come out uh within a month and I
discovered this line a few weeks ago
when working on the course and it's kind
of counterintuitive because Bishop takes
G3 seems to strengthen White's position
because white can either take with Pawn
or Knights but with options look fine if
Pawn takes then black has a very strong
move Knight G4
and this move looks a little bit random
at first but the knights really well
placed here and white can never really
get in this F3 E4 plan because F3 leaves
E3 hanging and there's white laughter
castles kingside then there's attacking
potential with Queen G5 to H5 or Pawn H5
on H4 so maybe for this reason he's not
taking with Pawn but he took with
knights and this is perhaps a more
natural approach
so I continue with development Knight A6
threatening Knights B4 he prevents it
with A3 and C7 castle and I was still in
prep and I knew one of the top engine
ideas was to play Pawn H5 I played this
pretty quickly you can see I really
haven't used much time so far this game
and H5 is a nice idea because I'm
threatening to play H4 and ideally H3
and try and weaken the king Side Pawn
structure in White's territory so
because of this threat my opponent very
quickly played Pawn H3 preventing my
Pawn from eventually getting to H3
an iPhone 96
and he played Rook a to D1 now I
actually had this position on my
computer uh before the game and it's
it's never been reached before
um not in the Masters database Lee chest
database oh it has been reached eight
times before but it's a pretty rare
position and uh the move I was looking
at before the game was uh B4 going for
the minority attack
but after Rook ad1 I was able to use the
same idea I Was preparing against B4 is
to play H4
and there is a trick with this move that
maybe at first it seems like white can
get away with Knight F5 and go after the
pawn but Knight of five is I think a
blunder here because there's a very
strong response Knight G5
and if white takes upon then after
Knight F to E4 this Knight is sidelined
and it can't really return without
having to deal with Knight takes F3 and
on top of that I'm threatened Knight
takes H3 and hitting the Knight with a
queen so this would be already I think a
very bad position for whites
and uh he did take some time maybe
trying to calculate these lines after I
played H4 and ultimately he played
Knight ge2 which I believe is the best
move
and here I continue Knight H5
and I was still within kind of my
pre-game preparation because I I checked
like the middle game idea from the
structure and the engine really likes uh
this move because it opens up the queen
and also restricts this knight from
coming to F4 in many cases uh we'll see
later why this is relevant
so game continues King H1 Knight G5 and
then he plays Bishop F5 so maybe trying
to prevent me from potentially sacking
on H3
uh I activate the queen with Queen F6 we
trade Bishops and then he plays Pawn to
B4 which uh I think is very logical he's
going for the typical minority attack
here I've had a decision to make I ended
up taking which I think is fine
um it's uh completely okay to just have
have this move thrown in and after it
takes well I really wanted to do here
was play Queen E6
idea being to sacrifice on H3 and I
thought there's a lion like King H2
Queen D6 like win the pawn but this
doesn't quite work because after the
king moves if I take the pawn I actually
get into a lot of trouble because Queen
F5
so I didn't go for this rather than
playing Queen E6 I played a move which
very much transforms the position Knight
to E4
and I was reluctant to play this move
because I wanted to keep my my pretty
nights on the king side maybe I should
have been a bit more patient and play
the move like G6 or maybe B5 I think the
engine likes B5 here
is one of the top moves but 94 I played
because
after takes takes this is what happened
the game I get this uh this Pawn on e4
and it looked like with this structure
Pawn on e4 and Pawn on H4 there's great
attacking potential eventually for black
and I had ideas here of eventually
playing G5 and G4 and trying to bust
open the king side also ideas of
bringing the Rook to the king side as
well we're gonna see that it's really
not so simple to attack and my opponent
played a series of I think pretty strong
moves starting with Queen C5 hitting my
Knights I defend with G6 and then he
plays B5 so it's still a minority attack
it's called a minority attack because
white has one Pawn minority and I have
two pawns but B5 is just a very thematic
Pawn break because after the trade I'm
left with this weak B7 pawn and even
though it's a pass pawn and maybe we're
heading towards an end game Pawn is way
more of a liability than the strength
so I defend rookie seven
and then he played well I think is a
very strong move and it seems like a
kind of innocuous move at first king G1
just seems sort of random but the idea
is white is over defending the F Pawn
which was pressured by my queen and
white eventually wants to play Rook C1
trade a pair of Rooks and then get this
F1 Rook active in the game
so after King G1 I took I think what was
one of my longest thinks of the game
just trying to figure out a game plan
and ultimately I decided to play a move
that was definitely not the first move I
considered was King to H7
and there were two reasons why I played
this move
and I'm going to take a sip of coconut
water so if you want to ponder why I
play King H7 feel free to take your time
so
King H7 there's a positional reason and
a more tactical reason
for one I was calculating the line Rook
C1
and
what I wanted to do was play Rook C7
and after takes takes
Rook C1 I had an idea to play Queen A6
in this position and the reason why I
want my king on H7 is so there's no
Queenie check
um because if white has Queen E8 then
white will win the rook and yeah it
doesn't work for black and I didn't play
King G7 because there'd be Queen E5
check and white is again winning the
rook and I was trying to get a position
where I forced a queen trade imagine
takes I can throw in the in-between move
takes takes takes and I was envisioning
this end game from when I was
calculating King H7 and I thought that
black actually has good chances to win
this because the outside pass Pawn can
be a very strong asset and
um yeah sometimes Knights are not great
at uh effectively covering the outside
pass pawns and also contributing to the
rest of the game
so that was one idea with King H7 and
the other idea
was a bit more tactical going back to
this position I wanted to free the G8
Square for my rook and I thought that if
he plays Rook C1 then I could go for the
line I just showed but I have an
additional option to play Rook Gates and
then eventually prepare G5 Queen G6 and
G4 and really try and
um just hammer away on the G file open
the G file and ideally someday Checkmate
on G2
so it was a pretty deep move I spent
what about 17 minutes to play this
but the game continues and he did not
play Rook C1 he played Rook D2 which is
just a patient improving move
I play G5 essentially just going for
this plan of Rook G8 and queen G6 and G4
like I was just showing yeah I felt like
momentum is still on my side like I have
a clear attacking plan but he found some
annoying moves he starts with Rook B1 I
play Queen G6 and then he plays Queen B6
and the thing here is I don't want to
trade Queens if I trade Queens I'll have
no attack and then B7 will be a more
clearing weakness so I play the move F6
and then he plays Queen D6
so basically what's happening I play
Rook G7 I'm putting everything on the
king side and just abandoning most of
the the the center and like the queen
side I'm just uh really trying to go all
in with my attack
um the problem ended up being after Rook
bd2 I really wanted to play G4 right
away but I don't think it quite works
because there's this move Knight F4 and
it's one of the drawbacks of pushing the
g-pawn I give away the F4 square and if
takes takes yeah I was calculating this
line but I couldn't quite make it work
because this move comes with check and
my each Pawn will hang and b7's hanging
so I had to play defensively after Rook
B2 I played Rook C7
he played King F1 which I think is a
useful move getting off the g-file
I attack the queen he plays Queen E6 and
then I figured that my knight is just
out of place so why not improve it with
Tempo I played Knight G7
he played Queen A2 I played Knight F5 I
still felt like there's momentum but
White's actually still very solid and he
plays an active move Rook B6
I play Knight D6
I had dreams here of playing Knight C4
hitting the rook and maybe someday
getting a fork or someday Queen F5 and
Knight takes E3 so white does have to be
careful
um so he played Rook C1 neutralizing the
C file and in this position
I kind of freaked out like I was already
getting pretty low on time falling below
10 minutes
and I took a long time to play this move
Knight C8 which I don't think is a good
move but I really wasn't sure what else
to do
the move I initially wanted to play was
Queen I5 and I think I was pretty close
to playing this but I'm pretty sure this
is a big blunder because of Rook takes
C7 Rook takes C7
oh yeah what am I saying uh I just lose
a knight
um what do they want to play then oh I
wanted to take I spent most of my time
calculating takes takes and then Queen
F5
which at first looks nice and active but
the reason why I didn't go for this is
Rook takes D6 happens and white is
winning material after takes
Queen F7 and wherever my king moves the
queen will deliver a check and pick up
the Rook
so
um yeah I've I resorted to passivity
played Knight C8
he plays Rook B1
I play Queen F5 so now I can activate
the queen without losing material
but then he plays Queen A4 and I'm still
under a bit of pressure
I brought my knight back to D6 and then
he plays Rook C5
and at this point I felt like I was just
getting off played and he was playing
quicker than me I'm below four minutes
he's still above seven minutes
um so I just had to respond to the
threats like Queen E6 and then he plays
Rook B6 so at some point something has
definitely gone wrong for me but I'm
still trying to hold on uh play Queen C7
he plays Knight C3 threatening this
nasty Fork
so I go back to C8 at this point I'm
just trying to like hold on for dear
life he plays Rook B4
I trade takes takes and now there's like
three attackers against that pawn only
one Defender so the only way to defend
the pawn is to play F5 I should note I
can't take on C5 because on the rookings
so F5 I played
I had to play quickly
um I'm hovering around a minute
and then he plays Rook T4
and at this point I thought I'm just on
the verge of losing because I have to
take
and I was expecting him to take with the
pawn here which I think leads to a very
very difficult position for black
because the c-pong restricts my knight
and uh these pawns look much stronger
than my uh clump of Pawns and D5 and D6
is coming but to my surprise he took
with the queen on D4
and this allowed me to just try and
simplify with Queen G7
and very quickly things fizzle out he
played Queen d8
I took his Knight he took my knight
and then I deliver Perpetual check
um I I really wanted to plan for a win
but there's really no practical way to
do so
and uh and yeah this was a game it was I
think a very hard-fought middle game I
don't know if he had any like strong
chances to win I think the moment
towards the end of the game where he
could have taken with Pawn was maybe one
of the best chances but we were both
getting a little on time
and uh yeah I think the the game itself
lasted about four hours and I have
another game to play in about half hour
so I'm gonna wrap it up so stay tuned
for the final round recap and for the
next recap my beard will be even bigger
so just you wait I'll see you guys soon